hi I'm miles Barnes developer advocate
for Google cloud platform and one of the
main Tanner's in node.js I hear you're
interested in deploying a node.js
application so I want to introduce you
to an amazing product offering available
in Google cloud platform nodejs on App
Engine standard is a great way to
quickly get your application or service
into the cloud
take your node project sprinkle a little
bit yeah mol run the magic command
g-cloud app deploy and you're ready to
go to demonstrate just how quickly you
can get your code up and running I'm
gonna highlight some of my favorite
features of App Engine standard while
deploying so here we have our package
JSON it's for our hello world
application you could see that our only
dependency is Express here is the server
JS file we create a single route that
always responds hello nodejs
and we listen on the default port last
but not least we sprinkle a tiny bit a
yam on the taste the only thing
remaining is to run the magic command
g-cloud app deploy so let's go to
terminal up and a timer and let's go
first off you're going to notice that
the code you write is idiomatic there is
nothing special or magic about writing
code for App Engine one of my favorite
features for App Engine standard is
scale to zero you only pay for the
compute you use we manage the runtime
for you when the operating system our
node get an update you're going to get
it automatically we also install all the
dependencies in the cloud for you prior
to deployment so you can be guaranteed
that your applications running in a safe
sandbox logging introspection live
debugging monitoring you get all of that
out of the box one HTTP we got you we
automate the process of generating
certificates for default or custom
domains well looks like our app is
already deployed so let's pop up in a
browser and take a look so there you
have it deploying nodejs to App Engine
standard with just three magic words
g-cloud app deploy thanks for joining us
today
I'm Miles boran's please feel free to
post any questions in the comments
section or ping me on twitter and at
myles boards